[Music]
you can always count on two things
happening at the MTV Video Music Awards
unique performances and memorable
moments good weird and sometimes shady
like this playful moment from cardi B at
the top of the show which fans thought
might have been a dig at Nicki Minaj's
new album Queen Travis Scott reminded us
his album is at the top of the charts
a day after Nicki Minaj called him out
on Twitter claiming his album sales were
boosted by his girlfriend Kylie Jenner
not only did Tiffany Haddish
mispronounced Camila Cabello stage she
also threw shade at Camilla's former
band Nicki Minaj clearly didn't love
that joke so don't become a fifth
harmony because normanni is that [ __ ]
meanwhile the Backstreet Boys presented
the award for song of the year and they
put their own spin on some hip-hop hits
booze and mellow features like a Rasta
it's a lot of bad things that they wish
you know me maluma ended his performance
with a steamy kiss with one of his
dancers and speaking of latin Superstars
and i witness inside the event tells ET
some fans were a bit confused that J
Lo's video Vanguard Award was presented
by Shawn Mendes an artist that she's
never worked with the evening ended with
Madonna paying tribute to the late
Aretha Franklin but some social media
users found her speech puzzling you're
probably all wondering why I'm telling
you this story there's a connection
because none of this would have happened
could have happened without our Lady of
soul
[Music]